another effective covet vaccine
but this one's homegrown key data from
clinical studies of 24 000 people
show the oxford vaccine is 90 effective
and may also reduce the spread of the
virus the first time that's been shown
with any of the jabs being prepared for
roll out
results also show there were no major
side effects
with 100 million doses pre-ordered for
the uk success of the oxford vaccine
is crucial it started over kind of cold
weekend
where i helped design the vaccine and
has progressed since then
and it just hasn't stopped for those
working on the vaccine
there's relief to be so close to the
finishing line
there have been tough times for me and
the family and for everybody involved
it's it's gotten to the stage that my i
don't think my children recognize me
anymore
and refer to me as daddy because that's
the default parent who takes care of
them
um but i think they're proud of me and
we need to do this this is what we need
to do
to hopefully help us get out of the
pandemic
hearing it didn't hurt at all the next
day
it was a bit painful lois was one of the
50
000 people worldwide to take part in
clinical trials
she's a medical student and had been
working in intensive care when the virus
hit
she felt helpless there was no treatment
so she did what she could to speed the
vaccines development
it just felt like something i could do
that like back in may it was really like
the
height of the first wave it was it all
felt really scary and it was just one
small thing i could do
i think a lot of people are going to get
a lot of benefit from it in ways that we
haven't even
thought about now like i mean like the
big things like there's not going to be
people in intensive care anymore
and small things like people can have
their relatives in hospital again
and then even smaller things like i can
get the train and see my parents and not
worry about
it i think it's going to change
everything
the oxford vaccine is based on a virus
that causes the common cold in
chimpanzees
the virus has been modified so it's
harmless and adapted to carry part of
the coronavirus
the genetic instruction to make its
unique spike protein
when the vaccine is injected the
modified virus
enters human cells decodes the
instructions
and makes the spike protein a bit like a
trojan horse
the immune system responds by producing
antibodies and t
cells that guard against future
infection with covid19
but a vaccine can only work if it's
rolled out quickly
the next challenge is going to be to get
enough people immunized
fast enough to have an impact on the
virus and that does take time i mean it
simply takes time to manufacture
to get the vaccines distributed and then
to get them into people's arms
um it can't just be done overnight so
the more vaccines
we've got the more doses of each of the
vaccines we've got
the easier that's going to be
this production line at voc heart plant
in wrexham
is ready to roll filling
vials with the vaccine four million
doses could be ready by the end of
december
with the rest to come next year if the
safety regulators give it the go ahead
and that decision is expected within
days
thomas more sky news